[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
I'm Dustin Kirkland here at
KubeCon in Copenhagen, Denmark.
And I'm joined by
Tim Hockin, who's
going to give us his thoughts
on a handful of the questions
that you've been
asking us this week.
Tim, you've been around
Kubernetes a long time.
I'd really like to hear
from you in your words
how Kubernetes is changing
the course of application
development and ultimately
IT operations at scale.
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
I think Kubernetes
containers and the sort
of orchestration model
is really changing
the way people are able to
think about their applications,
the way they think
about building them,
and the way they think
about running them.
In terms of building,
Kubernetes really
captures the
microservices model where
you can build lots
of small pieces
and link them together
into a larger application.
From the operations point
of view, from the IT side,
it lets you think about your
applications and your code
in a way that isn't
so one to one.
You don't think about which
machine is running which piece
of software, and you
don't think about how
you handle events and sorts
of things that go wrong.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
why is that important?
TIM HOCKIN: It's important
because things go wrong
all the time.
Right?
I mean everybody who's run
an application understands
the reality.
Things crash, and they
always crash at 2 o'clock
in the morning on a Sunday
when you are on vacation
after a night of drinking.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
But with Kubernetes,
that doesn't happen?
TIM HOCKIN: No.
Things still crash,
but Kubernetes
is designed to accept the
reality that things will crash.
And we will just move
it somewhere else
because the identity of the
machine that you're running on
is not that important.
Your application is
just a unit that we
can move across the
soup of your cluster,
and we can just bring
it up somewhere else.
We can let the system self-heal.
And if it takes a little
while for that crashed machine
to come back online,
maybe it takes a week,
maybe you have to buy a
new hard drive, that's
fine because you shifted
the load somewhere else.
And once people start to
internalize that idea,
it changes fundamentally
the way you
think about running your
applications in the cluster.
This is how we've been doing it
at Google more or less forever.
The idea of a machine, a
VM or a physical machine,
a server that runs my
application and just
my application is completely
foreign to the Google mindset
of how you build an application.
You throw it into the Borg
and it runs somewhere.
And so Kubernetes tries
to bring the best of that
to the open source world.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So Tim, you've
been around this technology
for a long time.
You've seen the evolution
of Borg at Google.
And in its early inception and
its migration into Kubernetes,
how did Google Developers
make that transition
to writing for Borg?
And how does that translate to
third party developers writing
for a Kubernetes that maybe
has nothing to do with--
they're quite detached from the
Kubernetes that's ultimately
going to run their application?
TIM HOCKIN: So with
Google and Googlers,
it was back in 2003-ish
when Borg started
to come into fruition,
and it really
was a very different
system than it is now,
but the ideas were the same.
Take a machine, share it
across multiple users,
put some isolation
barriers in place
so that you can provide
some level of guarantee
that you won't hurt each
other, that you can co-exist.
And it took a long
time for people
to give up the private
machine mentality, especially
for these big applications,
like search, where Google really
makes its money.
These were very difficult. They
have very strong requirements
in terms of performance
and guarantees.
And so it took a long
time for those apps
to come into the Borg ecosystem.
But once they did, their
lives are better for it.
They get the
consistent operations,
the existing tooling.
We have a very small cluster--
sorry-- very small team
of cluster administrators
who run the entire Google fleet.
And it's amazing because
the power of Borg
lets them scale that way.
So for people who are
outside Google, people
who are in the real world,
they look at Kubernetes,
and they see it
as this new thing.
They don't really know
what to make of it.
It's natural that people have
some amount of reluctance
to get into it.
But the more we show people,
the better off they will be.
I had a great
personal moment when
I was presenting at USENIX
LISA a couple of years ago,
room full of systems and--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Fantastic
conference, yeah.
TIM HOCKIN: And I showed them
some of what Kubernetes can do.
Just here's how you
do a rolling update.
Here's how you do a deployment.
Here's how you flip a
service from A to B,
and there were audible
gasps in the room.
How did you do that?
And that was great for me
because this is the mindset.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
I've seen that, too.
The developers who
come around and come
to understand how much
Kubernetes does for them so
that they can focus on
simply their application
packages as a container
and see that scaled out.
I think it helps
take, you mentioned,
it helps taking a
small IT team and turn
it functional at larger
scale even smaller,
but also helps one developer
or team of developers
create quite a bit
more technology.
TIM HOCKIN: For sure.
You don't need to
have a huge operations
team to run a big fleet.
And I think you can get away
with a very small ops team
if you've got a small fleet.
If you've got 100 nodes
in your fleet, which
is a pretty decent
sized compute fleet,
you can run a pretty big
website on 100 machines,
and you can really run that
with one or two people.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So you've seen
Google effectively democratize
that technology and make
that generally available
to practically anyone.
TIM HOCKIN: Absolutely.
I mean a big part of Kubernetes
was bringing these ideas
forward, but not just
the ideas on their own,
like a working implementation.
It was really important
for us to say, not only do
we believe you should
operate like this,
but we're going to
help you do this.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now
you've got a position
in the community
that enables you
to see a lot of the different,
hard, technical problems
around Kubernetes.
Can you give us a sense
of where some of the areas
are that need the most work?
And I'm talking less
code writing and more
like design decisions, some
of the big, hard problems.
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
Kubernetes is a big project.
It's got a lot of surface area.
One of the big
problems we have is
how to limit the growth
of that surface area.
We can't grow forever.
And so a ton of
work has been going
into things like extension
mechanisms and plug-ins
and hooks and making
those things really truly
usable for production
grade deployments, not just
prototypes.
And so a ton of work
has been going in.
A ton more work has to be
done and is being done now.
The community's amazing
and very vibrant here.
So this is one of the
thing's really interesting.
Another is in the growth
of the surface area,
you see a lot of new
challenges that were not
in scope when we started.
I work in the infrastructure
side of things, so networking
and storage.
So one example here
is Kubernetes growing
to fill more networking spaces.
Things that have
traditionally been
filled by classical,
virtualized networking,
NFVs, and virtual firewalls
and deep packet inspection
and all those sorts of things
that a lot of enterprises,
a lot of big companies
have been sold
that they believe in the
technology, the value
that it brings to their company.
How do you map
that to Kubernetes?
And you know--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Is it a place where
Kubernetes has to plug into
the way the enterprise already
operates?
It can't just wipe
the slate clean.
TIM HOCKIN: Some of it.
Some of that.
And some of it is really looking
at the problem with fresh eyes
and coming back
to it and saying,
what would be the Kubernetes
way of describing this problem?
So there's going to be
some blending there.
These are problems
that Google never had.
This is a place where Borg
just doesn't have anything
because it's not a problem
that Google deals with.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: What
are some of the projects
that you find most
interesting or some
of the interesting
innovations and developments
that are happening?
TIM HOCKIN: I'm a big
fan of the Istio project.
And not just because it
partly comes out of Google,
but I think the technology
is really interesting, really
exciting.
The demonstrations
that they can show you,
like look, we can
do this for you,
is on the level of the first
demonstrations of Kubernetes
of saying, look, we
can do this for you.
So it sort of gives
me that childlike glee
when I see somebody doing
something really cool.
There are so many
other projects.
I mentioned earlier the
networking and devices.
There's all the work around
ML and GPUs that is happening.
I think it's really
exciting stuff.
It's a really hot
space that's going
to really change the world
and probably obsolete me.
And its exciting to see these
people working on things,
but we got to figure out the
sort of principled models
with which we're working.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It
seems to be a good fit
so far with Kubernetes.
TIM HOCKIN: I can't
imagine it not being a fit,
but there's previous decisions
that we have to work through
in terms of compatibility
and in terms of how do we
fit these things in the system.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And then, who do you
find some of the most inspiring
people around the community?
TIM HOCKIN: The most
inspiring people--
I'm an engineer
through and through.
So I really look up to
folks like Clayton Coleman
from Red Hat, who is really
so fundamental to the project.
The project would
not be what it is
without him and his
team of awesome people
that they brought
to the project.
But I also look around
at some of the people
I work with at Google and
that I measure myself against.
There's guys like Brian
Grant, who is just a genius,
and Eric Tune, who
is just the best
engineer I've ever worked with.
These people are amazing to me.
And then, you look around
the rest of the space,
and there's all of these
brilliant, exciting people who
are out talking about Kubernetes
and evangelizing and showing
neat ideas.
And you don't need to
be core contributors
to be really exciting.
It's hard to pick any one.
I tend to pick, I
guess, the people
I interact with the most,
but there's so many--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Quite
a vibrant community
from that perspective.
TIM HOCKIN: So many people.
I'm going to spend all week
at KubeCon talking to people.
I doubt if I'll go
to a single talk.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And then,
do you have any advice
for maybe a university
student or a young engineer
just getting started
with Kubernetes?
How do they take
that first step?
TIM HOCKIN: How do you take a
first step into any open source
project?
You just start.
You just decide
you're going to do it.
You decide a problem that
you want to try to work on,
and you start reading code.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Get
cloned is the first step.
TIM HOCKIN: Get cloned.
Exactly.
And if you can start
from main, and if you
can start reading code
and comprehending it,
and you go an hour and you don't
find something you need to fix,
you're really not
looking hard enough.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I like it.
And then finally,
a question we're
asking all of our
interviewees here.
How did-- I have to stifle
a little bit of a laugh--
how did you get started
with Kubernetes?
TIM HOCKIN: So I was working
on the Borg team at Google.
Specifically, I was working on
the node side of the Borg team
and Omega working
on the node agent
so the equivalent of
kubelet in the omega side
was called omlet.
And we were working
on this, and we
were asked to work more
closely with a Cloud team
to see if we could find ways to
synergize to not duplicate work
so much.
And at the same time,
this Docker thing landed.
People started
talking with Docker.
And we looked at it, and said,
wow, this is kind of neat.
It's sort of what we've got
going on inside omlet, wordlet.
I could sort of see how this
could turn into an open source
Borg, which is something that
we had pitched to our leadership
before, but we didn't really
have the momentum behind it.
And then, a few folks
at Google took this
and ran with a prototype.
And they showed us this
very simple mock-up
that they threw together,
and it was amazing.
It was immediate,
like I see this.
I get it.
This is something.
And so the opportunity to
work on this was there.
And I said I would like to
help take this from prototype
into reality.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Cool.
And now I want to
eat an omelette.
I don't know why.
All right.
Thanks Tim.
I appreciate it,
appreciate your time here.
TIM HOCKIN: Thanks.